but we do have a very special guest with
us yeah is one thing that the see Lewis
chess club has expanded to in recent
years is may now have a young
professionals board and we have Ramona
Grisanti who is with Maurice Ashley to
talk about it yes her moniker Sonya and
who is the branch manager and vice
president at Busey bank
Ramona welcome to the show tell us about
PC bang
so Busey bank is a community
organization that really is committed to
helping its customers and the community
fulfill their dreams we have been around
since 1868 so we're celebrating our one
hundred and fiftieth anniversary Wow yes
what are you doing to celebrate all
kinds of events throughout the year
promotions when I say fulfilling dreams
there's literally contests on our social
media that you can submit and enter into
our contest to win you are head of the
young professionals board here tell us
what you guys do I remember we had a
great party basically there was a lot of
dancing going on is what I remember it
was a great and you are good dancer I
think yes so for the young professionals
board we really kind of kick started off
with doing a first happy hour with
another organization here in Central
West End that central sent a Association
and us we collaborated together for this
happy hour and then since then we've
been able to put on the chest after dark
events to kind of recruit new members
and really spread the awareness of the
chess club that was an amazing event I
wish we had pictures of that because it
was such good I think we do have
pictures we do we had that fun photo
booth so I'm sure I can dig up some
pictures yeah it was such an amazing
colorful adventure that the dark they
need to bring that back yeah how did you
guys get involved in chess though what
why chess thinkit's itself art yes yes
so we started a few years ago really the
bank's sponsor the annual charity golf
tournament and with that we sponsored a
team of four players which are all Busey
bank employees and we use that day to
really build onto that relationship
between the two different organizations
and have sponsored it ever since
yeah we see right here this the golf
clinic Oh Country Club one
well this is something that will happen
because it says October 1st 2018 yes is
what will be becoming we're going to
have anymore chess events big chess
events yeah we are hoping to we're
planning on hopefully be one it would do
one more this year for the young
professionals board and then continue on
to next year with something similar to
chess after dark if not maybe I'm gonna
be around for the next event what is it
gonna happen well we're gonna have to
make sure you're here so at a time that
there's got to be dancing involved
otherwise absolutely always I know
you're just just quickly you're a
basketball fan I believe I am I am any
correlations between chess and
basketball you can think of who's your
favorite players in basketball I don't
watch basketball but I played it you do
fly school yes yeah alright well that's
cool that's cool
basketball is my favorite sport so that
makes that makes you cool oh there we go
so we can continue doing these events
yes you're allowed Ramanna christening
of Busey bank doing great work for the
community check them out